and so I lost my son essentially your
son is dead so my son Xavier is dead
killed by the and we're going to see the
hypocrisy of Elon Musk why because when
it is his
son brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £1 p is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing D that you want to do but
we turn it into a money-making machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subh bless and preserve
you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends if you guys remember remember
Elon Musk before he got brainwashed and
bought out by the Zionist movement if
you remember there was an interview of
him saying what that he was basically
saying I mean imagine basically
criticizing Israel he was saying that if
you go and say if you go and Commit This
atrocities and kill men women and
children you are only supporting Hamas
by recruiting for them why because
people are looking and thinking my mom
my innocent family members got blown up
to Pieces Subhan Allah I'm going to go
and join Hamas in the or or the or the
resistant Army which the UN has given
them a clear guideline that they have a
right to defend theirself you know hate
Israel so really the question is like
for for every Hamas member that you kill
how many did you create now you were all
thinking where did that come from here
is where that psychological trauma goes
back to and we're going to see the
hypocrisy of Elon Musk why because when
it is his son that actually died not
literally died by the way let's find out
how here's an interview with his dirt
scumbag Jordan Peterson it happened to
one of my my older boys um uh where I
was um I was essentially tricked into uh
signing documents uh for one of my older
boys Xavier uh this is before I had
really any understanding of what was
going on and we had co co going on and
so there was a lot of confusion um and
um you know I was told oh you know
Xavier might commit suicide if if he
that was a that was a lie right from the
outset incredibly evil and I agree with
you that people that have been promoting
this should go to prison so I was I was
straight into doing this um and uh you
it wasn't explained to me that puberty
blockers are actually just sterilization
drugs um so I mean just look at it
carefully look how distraught he is the
way he's talking that he was been
tricked and they lied to him he signed
documents Etc this happened to his son
look at his demeanor and let's carry on
in the second half watch this
carefully um anyway uh and so I lost my
son essentially uh so you know they uh
they call it dead naming for a reason
yeah all right so the reason it's called
deadnaming is because uh your son is
dead so my son Xavier is dead killed by
the woke mind virus I'm sorry to hear
that yeah I can't imagine what that
would be
like yeah
so and imagine the hypocrisy of Jordan
Peterson I cannot imagine what they
would be like you are the same dirt back
who said give them hell and hundreds now
this the the new stud say 180,000 people
have been massacred do you know how many
of them are kids yeah you how many kids
carry watching just carry watching gets
interesting
watch um yeah and there's lots of people
in that situation now it's not pretty
and lots of demolished kids yeah well
that's a good that's a good reason to be
the final straw all right so let's so I
vowed to destroy the the work my virus
after that and we're making some
progress join the club yeah now
interesting he even like basically call
his son dead why because he got his
private part castrated now this of
course it's horrific Etc there are
Israeli snipers that are targeting young
Palestinian boys in the private part and
this scumbag Elon Musk defends them how
does it feel and so does this dirt bag
Jordan Peterson you're talking about one
child who is still alive who's been
frustrated with their own will by the
way with their own well you can call it
beam brainwash whatever it's for matter
and what did IL say he says I vow to
destroy the woke mind virus H I wonder
where that trauma came from when he was
talking about basing saying those people
are going to go andjoy Hamas I wonder
why because he realized the one that did
that to his son he wants revenge he
wants to destroy them you saying it with
his own mouth that virus because I want
to get rid of it what about the
thousands hundreds of thousands of kids
babies that have been massed what do you
think that does to the Palestinians and
their resistance and them wanting to
join Hamas do you think it stops them do
you think they say oh we do not want to
fight back and we don't want to go and
join Hamas whatever it is for that
matter okay do you think they do that no
so you can see the utter hypocrisy
Subhan Allah your own son went through
that and you are here defending a nation
defending a group of State terrorists
zionists you are defending them of them
massacring thousands of people shame on
you shame on you Subhan Allah and that
is where that trauma was coming from
when he was talking about that until he
had to get pressure and get paid off I
don't say paid off God knows what
pressure put there or God knows what
videos they have of him or God knows
what they have of him that subh Allah
that he changed his stance on the whole
situation that's all I wanted to say in
subh brother sisters as you can see
Subhan Allah the farle one to take the
soul of our kids by making them leave
their religion and the far right and
those who sport Elon Musk and Jordan
Peterson they want to take the life of
our brances in Palestine may Allah subh
deal with them all inshah